today on our show wonder where have you
in Wonder Woman
today I'm talking about men well Batman
a Batman I'm Kevin Smith hi I'm mark
Barnard and if I wasn't a heavy guy I'd
be sterling right now just like Lynda
Carter
to turn into my fat man persona and come
here and review the very first ever live
action
Wonder Woman film yes we saw it last
week
mmm how novel we're gonna review the
movie having seen it as opposed to other
way when we review the movie sight
unseen and Joe I don't know cracked like
really I got for that movie with the
pilot [ __ ] why did they bother this is
not quite the case of this movie as I
mentioned on Twitter I mentioned the
last episode of fat man I'm Batman we
were to screening mark got us into a fan
screen Van Alen screening the warner
brothers held warner brothers been
having a lot of fans craving Juniata so
much enthusiasm for this movie and not
that they needed to work very hard no
isn't selected a lot of people want to
see for a long long time including the
woman in our screening lights went down
just for the credits rolled she yelled
out I've been waiting my whole life for
this and that set the tone right away
there's no discounting the number of
people who've been wanting a Wonder
Woman movie for their entire life and no
discounting that their gender is also
not mine
like I've gone into a movie theater many
times and had this experience I look up
on the screen and I see somebody who is
a male and he's doing heroic things and
he's putting on costumes that I know
from the comics and I'm thrilled and I'm
satisfied and you know I'm not looking
to identify because I'll never do that
[ __ ] but like you know I I know what
that feels like every movie I've ever
seen almost crossed my entire life yeah
I can look at the main character or one
of the main characters and be like all
right I can identify on some level yeah
you don't have to do that extra work to
find your way into a movie the movies
are made for you and there's been many
movies like hey what about bug of Star
Wars Princess Leia of course they've
been movies would have been strong
female role models or strong female
heroines the guardians of the galaxy
Gamora
one of them right there but there's
there's but a handful of movies that
exist in this zone in the action pulp
genre zone that are formed around a
female character around which everything
else revolves which the narrative serves
around which the world bends and yeah
you can almost count them on one hand
and that's why we want to see ghost in
the shell oh no that's that little bit
what we went to see Wonder Woman this is
a huge advantage here DC Comics not
great to see that's you know if you're a
guy oh my god Wonder Woman finally on
the screen and they gave you Wonder
Woman that didn't look like the TV
wonder woman who was wonderful for her
era but they gave us a Wonder Woman in
the movie that looks like the one a
woman from a of the comics and be the
cartoon so for the first time you're
seeing her soar in the air use a sword I
mean we saw her use a sword BBS's right
I guess she did a lot of these things
about maybe super yeah but I mean I
remember that being one of the most
exciting parts about men do something
like hope that's what a woman and a man
and man it in and then and then and then
one time I went up I should have
harmonized you add it to should've
trusted you
which me my friend yes it was absolutely
like that that aspect of BBS was one of
the only aspects nobody argued about
people weren't like this that they were
like we all dug wonder when we all love
our music yeah and they give more of
that she there's so many fighting
sequences in this movie where she'll
burst her door and kick the ass of like
10 people and stuff which you know I was
like oh that's cool Wonder Woman's doing
it but for a large segment of the
audience it's much it's a much bigger
deal than oh that's cool Wonder Woman's
the lead in the movie or something it's
somebody looking up and being like as
the lady said for the movie I've waited
my whole life to look up on the screen
and see my character when I identify
with like writ large and unleashed and
I'm not going to say thank God they
waited but like now that they have
waited they can really serve that
character in the digital age it was the
action seekers were phenomenal and patty
Jenkins had directed not really known
for no like monster you know I mean
she's not lying monsters not known for
like remember that interests amazing
action sequence it's like she directed
Charlize Theron to an Oscar which is
you know not like it's the hardest thing
in the world to do but it takes skill
and deafness and talent but you're
absolutely right that's not the person
who like you know who I want to roll my
turn million dollar superhero movie on
on that director they're smart to do it
though not the least of which of the
reasons they you got a movie called
Wonder Woman
you better have a woman directing it ten
years ago 20 years ago probably wouldn't
been the case but more importantly you
got Academy as Mark pointed out someone
who the Academy in favors like this is
legit filmmaker so they trusted her with
200 million bucks and she gave him an
action movie better than anything better
than any action movie I ever could have
[ __ ] given him I'll be honest with
you I watch that flick and I was like
wow that sequence is fantastic that
sequence is fantastic the movie ends
with a giant like Snyder s action
sequence in the dark with things flying
and stuff like that but even that
[ __ ] look good like she gal gadot gal
gadot like you know I remember when they
first cast her there were bunch of
people on line go and she's too skinny
shouldn't Wonder Woman be you know
Amazonian I thought she's wonderful I
thought she really nailed it that was a
surprise for me too I mean and I liked
her in the Fast and Furious movies was
the only place I'd seen her before
there's never seen she's really charming
yeah yes yes she's beautiful not you
know whatever like you're not you're not
casting anybody in the movie like this
who's not beautiful so let's just put
that aside but she's really charming
yeah you know she when she smiles you
absolutely understand why people respond
to her and Chris Pine who has always
been one of my favorite actresses I
guess I saw what smokin aces is where I
first saw him when he kills Ben Affleck
and it makes Ben's dead body talk like
this guy's wonder watch and then of
course has been an amazing Curtin uh he
I'm not because a he steals the show but
he is their secret weapon yeah because
he gets to be the audience he is Tom
Hanks and splash he is all of us going
this never happened before yeah like he
gets to be the one he gets to be the
audience who understands why you follow
one two a minute to battle why why you
rally behind her and he's our a
photographer that sort of thing and they
had a lot of fun fish-out-of-water stuff
between them like their comedic scenes
are really wonderful yeah I mean in that
that is one of the the tonal shifts from
this movie compared to get a Man of
Steel or BBS Oh
is that there's the legit sense of humor
to this it's not like dark humor it's
not like anything human and it also
doesn't feel like oh [ __ ] we had a test
screening everyone thinks it's too sad
put some jokes in like it feels like it
was organically part of the process from
the start like him him falling in love
with her is crucial to the way the story
works and so you have to show us that
you have to build that relationship and
that's the way they do it I guess
they're both impossible beautiful but
they're also really charming too they're
funny together and you get why they
respond to each other
samus Kira is beautifully depicted and
whatnot and they did stuff that like you
know my god I don't think I ever thought
about like how it is unseen to anyone
passing by in the vod's and then like
when the dude puts his head through the
force field like [ __ ] like that was kind
of cool they did a different origin
story than I'm the customer so okay
spoilers yeah spoilers lots of spoilers
five four three two one
she's a woman we didn't know I don't
spoil it for it yeah and also they're
all gay yeah they well there is
reference at one yeah where she talks
she has a conversation with Chris Pine
where she's like you know we concluded a
long time ago that men are necessary for
procreation but not pleasure
right which to me was like that's that's
the [ __ ] on the down low that was her
saying like oh I've come before yeah so
what we understand reproductive biology
we don't need it here yeah and also
there's nothing you can give me that's
any better than what we're getting back
home and they also come up with good
explanation for who she is like in terms
of you know for years she's at a very
convoluted kind of like you know one
point she's like she's formed from clay
and given life by Zeus and stuff and in
other versions not so much I always
Paradise Island like kept Hippolyta's
daughter and stuff like that but now you
know some of her origins include her
being formed from [ __ ] clay yes they
found a way to make it all work
they they absolutely just tied it all
together nice little bow really like
probably the cleanest best easiest to
understand origin of one of them the one
I am familiar with of course is you know
Diana is not allowed to leave the island
and Steve Trevor lands and man's world
what the [ __ ] and we must send an
emissary from of the
Amazon's and who will whoever bests in
battle you know livers the best gets to
go with Steve Trevor off the island and
you know she puts on the mask and then
sides undercover and fights and then it
is me mother and then she gets become
one woman so they don't do that I
stretch of the imagination this is we
don't want you to leave Steve Trevor
lands here brings a bunch of other
German dude which I've never seen I mean
I can't say I've read every Wonder Woman
comment comic in my life and I'm sure
there have been men on Paradise Island
since Steve Trevor but I thought that
was a cool aspect to bring into the
trailer like he's being chased he's a
spy he's being chased by the German
forces world war one which again
interesting choice
you know the pre-world War I this I've
always been like come on why not World
War two man [ __ ] chicken punch Hitler
in the face but give Marc a single give
he's got good reason well tell him why
World War one is better
I mean World War one was a [ __ ]
charnel-house of carnage like there was
just it was the it was the the bridging
period between the old way of waging war
and the new way here those Panzer tanks
coming up right now not in World War one
they don't have those you know the
mechanized infantry wasn't nearly as
prevalent they had artillery and they
had gas
but they were so marching into battle
without camouflage it was oh they were
still bayonet bayonet it was a little
like literally warring each other there
was still like the the commanders of
battalions would be on horseback because
that's the way it felt like war used to
be done and so this was the the turning
point for how efficiently you could kill
a vast amount of people and so putting
Wonder Woman into their like old world
new world you know dawning of
realization about what it means to be
human and what it means to commit
yourself to an ideal world war one works
really well for that and also we just
saw Captain America be the hero of World
War two I don't I'm imagining that DC
was like we don't like they claimed it
let's go back to the war nobody talks
about anymore
yeah the Forgotten world wars every
movies and you're absolutely right it's
like like who is she
if not a comic book superhero that's
like punch be good you got to get in
close for that kind of [ __ ] and World
War Two was about let's put more
distance between us on the enemy
so I speak they didn't quite have you
know the war at sea was not what it was
the air war was not what it was and
World War two so it's still if there
could be such a thing as at an innocent
war yeah or at least the loss of
innocence war is what World War one was
was no-man's land a real thing it really
was there was you know good maybe I was
what I chosen someone who done where was
just like would it be great to see
Wonder Woman crossing no man yeah like
trench warfare like there's a hundred
yards between the German lines and the
halide lines and nobody could cross
because it was just this this blood
field of you got to head up you got your
head shot off and that for me was the
most amazing scene in a movie for any
number of reasons but the symbolic of
you know a bunch of dudes hunker down
afraid to get out of no-man's land
everybody dies it's called no-man's land
for a [ __ ] reason and she just sheds
her cloaking for the first time you see
the armor and she climbs up a ladder in
slow motion and the armor but you know
the rest of her is like skin yeah so
there you are in this bleak I'm you've
seen in the trailer yeah they sold the
movie on it but you haven't hit it there
she is climbing up the ladder to the
battlefield you know wearing just her
armor carrying a sword and shield and
like taking artillery gunfire yeah
breathtaking I mean and it's it's the
it's a turning point of the movie it's
the oh [ __ ] he or she is doing what
she's born to do and all the guys behind
her were afraid or like she's taking all
the fire like she's distracting them we
can flank we can do things because she's
here this would not work if not for
Wonder Woman it's a glass and like it
right sequence like that and I mentioned
on Twitter like there's a moment that
movie that made me cry and that's it and
it's it's less because like yes it's
very well executed and she's really good
in it but what that means mm you know
the if I'm if I'm an 11 year old girl if
I've ever been an 11 year old girl and
I've never seen this before it's an
immensely powerful moment yeah and it
started out you don't even have to wait
that long in the picture watching The
Princess Bride leap into the air go
backwards and fire three arrows and the
[ __ ] dudes with guns who are like oh
[ __ ] watching the Amazonians watching
Hippolyta jump off a horse and [ __ ]
slaughter two dudes it's at the beach
sequence is [ __ ] AMA and they give it
to you early in the movie they're not
hiding no I when I saw Charlie I was
like oh they must at the end it gets
I got a defendant [ __ ] in the first 15
minutes of the movie they have a war on
the beach where you watch Amazon's go
[ __ ] crazy broad daily ah yes nothing
in the dark that's really cool you
rarely see that in a comic book movie
yeah I mean the the Avengers not
Avengers Civil War the airport sequence
very well Marvel Marvel is all about
daylight like like New York is getting
destroyed at noon yeah maybe ever you're
catching a four o'clock flight out of
like crazy Airport villain Civil War but
this was we are on a beach the sun is
shining and carnage is being waged and
it's awesome yes but it was reviewed
what a wonderful suite and I was the
lasso sequence where you actually see
them use the the lasso of Hestia see on
on Steve was wonderful funny stuff
coming back to England
you know the fish-out-of-water story
setting up the god-killer you know which
I mean you know I were I'm a writer so
right away when she was like you know
this sword a sous gave us the guy is you
know yeah I saw what they were doing so
they're doing even if she didn't know
yeah which is fine good time but I will
I will say that that no man's line
sequence both the crossing the trenches
and then the post-game of that in this
little French another phase of France
Belgium they were speaking of Belgium
village where she just destroys an
entire like brigade of like [ __ ]
armoured staff and soldiers and whatever
is as good a sequence as I've seen in
almost any Marvel movie oh right on
I praise I think I praise from mark
barnard eyes normally like [ __ ] it in
its mouth log in his mouth
I think it's just shy of like the
airport scene in Civil War and
definitely just shot in New York scene
in Avengers but from a solo Marvel movie
like a simple Captain America Iron Man
Thor made martemucci say a Minotaur game
movie maybe another teen movie where you
get me holy [ __ ] it's everybody but
we're following one hero in one journey
it is as good as any scene as I seen in
any model movie put that on a poster
it's long worth you can shop and take
the most relevant part send it to me for
approval but everything he said was
absolutely dead
is a wonderful sequence the once you get
to America well America once you get to
Britain and into the throes of World War
one she they get a ragtag collection of
people together as we saw in the photo
from Batman V Superman the whole thing
is predicated on a flashback of her
getting the photo from Bruce Wayne yeah
Wayne Enterprise this weird framing
sequence where she's a curator of
weapons at the Louvre because they
probably have one of those and that
Almer truck pulls up with his glass
plate of a photo that photo like her and
Chris Pine and an Indian guy and a
Native American guy and not a black guy
cuz still World War one hahaha but like
a Scottish guys spud is five shows up of
Trainspotting good but that's the like
look here as I gaze daily stare back
into my own mists of memory and recant
the tales I found I won World War one
she puts together her own little
Superfriends - yes our little Howlin
commandoes yes and they then your
villain let's talk about your villains
you got what's-his-name Tony Houston
Danny Green and Danny Huston we've seen
in the trailers the arcing in German ah
whoo yeah as like a no bear invention
you allow you to find out that's
something we need to point out a gal
gadot hasn't was it rarely access she's
really and so all of the Amazons I'm
famous Kara because gal can't do any
other accent everybody's got to do an
Israeli accent of Connie Nielsen Connie
Nielsen and Robin Wright Robin Wright
and everybody everybody they all
essentially the Amazon famous Kira is
off the coast of Israel I guess
apparently that's what their act and
it's also like the unit United Benetton
of to mascara because there's like black
Amazons and Asian Amazon's or white
Amazon's but they're all speaking as if
they're from a kibbutz somewhere just
approach to like how do you solve this
problem
like everybody talk like that okay
good make sense go ahead and action so
uh villains villains he was he's
anything but he's your bait in Swissvale
and she
yeah sorry Linden door failing his his
name of Dylan he's a villain and I think
the villains are the problem
for me where this movie is like as much
as I love the middle and the front end
of it the back half of this movie begins
to give them muddy and a little like
both cinematically like it gets very
dark and very third Aggies it's not the
beach fight sequence yeah sir fight in
the big bed and it's it plays not like
or like this is not dismissive but it's
plays kind of like the ending of Batman
V Superman and Suicide Squad it's in the
dark right there's a bunch of people and
there's floating ladies and dudes and
there's not a ring of garbage in the sky
not a real garbage in the sky but there
is a bunch of atmospheric fire because
fire is cool I guess and she can jump
and fly and leap and fight at the bag
I'm like everybody knows with bad guys
right like now I'm not gonna say who is
the bad guy but I mean Ares everyone
knows Ares is in the movie and to be
fair you know they're not showing this
in any of the trailers or any of the
footage that's released like if you're a
comic art book
hardcore comic book guy or girl and
you're like well I see her in the outfit
but there any other DC villains yes and
in costume yes oh yes you'll get your
fill of that doctor poison with that new
from the comments that doesn't oh yeah I
don't know I'm not sure I should have
looked that up before we start my beep
Wonder Woman knowledge is not apparently
that deep that didn't sound familiar
Annalise but for all we know maybe she
was plucked from Wonder Woman comics
right but like the problem for me with
the villains is that you know Wonder
Woman is going her agenda is to kill
areas but his Ares is the source of all
strife on earth and because Ares is
there there's a war where 25 million
people are dying so she wants to kill
Aries Aries who were led to believe is
Lyndon Dorf has no idea who Wonder Woman
is no so his agenda has nothing to do
with your hero like they are not by
witness evidence of the scene where he's
like wow who are you like they meet for
the first time dancing and then she's
trying not to kill him but he has no
idea who she is
yeah it's a weird seeing she was just
like ah coming happy but why did I take
your parking spot you know so like it
doesn't do that thing where you have
the hero and the villain on a collision
course because they both have an agenda
that each of them are intrinsically
involved with is that how that's done I
mean it's like that's what you get out
of the mark Bernard I mean you taught me
some [ __ ] so they they weave that whole
cloth yeah as you're we've got your bad
guy want something good guy want
something yeah I mean look at Indiana
Jones it's that they both want the ark
Balok knows exactly who Indiana Jones is
they meet they know they're both on the
same track in Cairo when Marion dies and
Belloc shows up and they have that
little conversation but you want to talk
to God life you pick out all of that
[ __ ] like they are both aiming for the
same thing they're both aware of each
other and so by the time they get to the
well of the souls by the time they get
to that Island out in the middle of
nowhere they are so involved in each
other story that you can imagine the
movie without them this movie doesn't
have that because your villain has no
idea your hero is an Avengers age of
Ultron has that right
Wednesday role because Tony creates
Ultron like it's right there what about
Gardens the galaxy the no one um who's
the bad guy I mean technically egos the
bad guy nigo knows exactly who Peter
cool is you know and Wow
and it's all like you know what I'm
starting to understand mark is a formula
to these guys I'm starting to see the
strings here I mean it's not rocket
surgery if you're going to do like a
standard level like here's a heroic
story your villain has to be
intrinsically involved with the life of
your hero otherwise it doesn't have the
same resonance by the time you get there
and granted they do do a thing in the
last you know 10 minutes of the movie
that that kind of brings it back around
again the Ares of it all the Ares of it
all died into her origin way back in the
day right but he's still and and he had
met Diana along the way but never in an
oppositional way never na I know what
you're doing Elena everyday I'm trying
to stop you way yeah it is over even I
know who you are away really right you
know so yeah until the very end so it
just it's out of balance a little bit
like it doesn't it doesn't land with the
same path that you feel like it should
land and then the movie thinks it lands
which is a place of she's overcoming her
sort of baser instincts to realize that
it's not about Ares like killing Ares is
not your
on earth you know helping the people of
helping mankind is your mission on earth
she takes a life she takes one she takes
a lot of lives I mean but I mean she'd
like does one like like real like yes
stab you to the heart and then she's
like nothing happened I don't get it yes
you thought that would you know having
big war they are they're a little
careful about the sort of judge or level
violence that she does we she'd like
burst into you know sniper's nest and
NNN holy crap that was amazing I like if
you're when I watched the movie I was
like my wife's gonna love a powerful
woman like bashes a church steeple open
just stands there some kind of
statements being made there and my
wife's gonna really like it but I mean I
the whole sequence - I've always loved
the idea of one woman and I think it did
started like Wade dealt with a little
bit in the JLA but the idea that she's a
God for all intents and purposes a God
of War like she comes to the battlefield
with a shield and a sword you don't come
to the battlefield the so unless you
willing to use it she's the one who
kills you no justice in the Justice
League she's the one who and also the
one for whom you have no kryptonite
right like she's just Wonder Woman
there's no like it's not that you just
do who could run out of money it's not
that you have a giant glowing media
thing it's how you're afraid of fire or
you could not tap into the Speed Force
or whatever it is I was waiting for the
spears or what's Flash's weakness you
know you'd lost your ring it's she's
always wondering yeah and so to watch
her just [ __ ] wail on people and kill
lots of that yeah it was bad for me
pretty dope I know like [ __ ] yeah
alright do that [ __ ] and I guess you're
right there is a kind of like morality
to it where it's like man she's not like
she's a god yeah she doesn't have to be
like it's very parallel to the Superman
story which is like Superman was raised
among humans who innately knows that
they are worth saving this is a movie
about her realizing that that humanity
is a good thing not just because they're
actually good but because they're trying
to be good but she's respecting the
effort to be good and that's that's a
powerful thing it just the tail end of
this movie just doesn't stick the
landing in the way you wanted to I
stepped on the dog um it was if I was a
little disappointed
that there was I could have used a
little more DC Universe for me like when
our bad guy shows up in his outfit I was
like oh yeah oh onset mascara I mean
that's I realize going in like I'm
looking I just want the fan porn I just
want to like hear the words I just want
to see the images that I've seen in
comics or bla bla bla so I you know I'm
looking I like this movie quite a bit I
I think it's in terms so far it's the
best of the post Nolen right Warner
Brothers DC Universe stuff
yeah warm and inviting it feels like the
right balance and stuff but you know
[ __ ] what was the original point I was
Megan I don't know yeah I mean like like
I have no I was gonna say zone him [ __ ]
you [ __ ] I forget what pointless [ __ ]
glad you - yeah I mean I have issues
with the movie I have issues with most
movies and that's fine
but I feel like to certain degree the
fact that it exists is in and of itself
is noteworthy and remarkable the fact
that it exists will get you over the
fact that when you sit through the
credits there is no PS yeah come on guys
come on do it
unless that was the thing that was
saving for theatrical release I thought
that what is marvel has done before like
when you first saw Iron Man they took
out that yeah that's enough yeah I
wonder I wonder if there will be a PS
scene or something right now we sat
through the credits and we wrote a lot
of theater did but what I would say like
oh like totally 80% of the audience was
like Marvel has trained us never to
leave until after the changes - it
really was a blow and then all then the
lights came up and really but alright I
know what I was going to say so as much
as I enjoyed this movie and and World
War one worked way better than I
imagined it would now I'm ready for
Wonder Woman movie set in current
continuity fighting cheetah I know it
sounds lame and [ __ ] but I just like
that's what I want to see like that's
when that's when I will know were in an
absolutely normal world but like you
know we made a Wonder Woman movie where
she fought cheated it was one of the
five Wonder Woman movie
made so I'm looking forward to the I
can't wait now it may be more excited
for Justice League yeah and her role in
Justice League and Shecky summit and it
made me more excited for Wonder Woman
sequels yeah bring it like this at this
point there's no reason for us not to
get it one of them is equal in the way
that we've never got a Man of Steel
sequel yeah learn from that mistake
don't just feel like because you know I
just rewatched man steal the morning
after I watched Wonder Woman and like
they were doing something yeah like were
they kind of BBS to though on stuff yes
so do you still go back and make another
one you could like what Android Java
versus Brainiac movie would be cool
yes I'll I can recover quite a bit yeah
like I loved him in that the tutors yeah
this everyday so those writing is so
good it's really good in Man From UNCLE
in film but doesn't give money wasn't
talking it up give us some love yeah no
I mean Man From UNCLE is it's a movie
nobody saw it came out like August 2
three years ago Guy Ritchie picture is a
remake of the sixties TV show with with
Robert Vaughn and you know you ever
played Illya Kuryakin yeah name I can't
remember but it's a [ __ ] 60 spy romp
it's like we want to do James Bond every
week but like buddy-cop it's like I spy
but with spies right and and it has a
the movie has a ton of heart to it it
bounces really well it's really fun it's
got all of this like 60s super awesome
feel like vauban thing while you're
sucking Guy Ritchie's dick sucking a
little more tell them what you just saw
I [ __ ] Arthur I should I take Arthur
like I believe to go remember remember
he's the one that was I see King Arthur
there whether you're seeking like you
know the movie Terry did I wasn't you
know I still want Camelot 3,000 more
than I wanted King Arthur you know what
would you say Andrew like yes la la I
can a lot from and it's very much like
why why is he history red why okay sure
I guess he's a scrapper but that being
said it's super fun you had a good time
he told me before we started he's like I
really actually like the Jude Law is
basically playing Morrissey as the king
of the you know really so it's just he's
like a depressed rock star for the
entire move
just glowering and why can I have what I
want I don't understand why am I so sad
bring me ball power like like swinging
from flagons of Winans what's your gonna
round it's so much fun he's just chewing
the scenery absolutely like not a piece
of it they escaped his mouth man they
get my money when I hit side toons yeah
so I mean Cavill [ __ ] I would watch
another Man of Steel movie with him I
especially like Superman's mythos is
rich like you know and we know we they
killed him in BBS but and he got to be
you got to be dumb has come to not know
he's coming back in the Justice League
movie so once he's back hopefully they
give him a man is still too just like
they do Wonder Woman to and Wonder Woman
to look I'll even give you this if
Wonder Woman 2 is like well Wonder Woman
was world war 1
Wonder Woman 2 is gonna be World War 2
I'm okay with that as long as she
punches some Nazis in the [ __ ] bush
fantastic but they must get to Wonder
Woman of the present one of them
fighting cheetah I know I keep saying
cheetah like she's the only one to one
villain but she thought I'd be badass
dude it would rat lady and [ __ ] fighting
Wonder Woman somebody some writer better
than me come up with a cool story make
it happen make it work don't be afraid
of the fact they like she's a god can't
fight cheetah anymore [ __ ] lady
running around looking like a cat you
see how much that play cats made that's
what this movie would make one of them
to cheat in it
all the money's come in now he loved rum
tum curve yeah but you agree with me on
that saying jump on the cheetah train
but you agree with me that bring the
character into it yes I mean that's
that's the the genius move it that the
first cat made which was we're gonna
tell a World War two story and then the
very last bit of it he's now there's
Nick Fury unaccounted I'm here too yeah
they told the movie at the end she's
back in the pros hey look it's me Diana
just looking through my sketchbook
remembering [ __ ] again yeah whatever but
like yes there's totally a way that at
this point this should be contemporary
or at the very least like yeah
doo-doo-doo Afghanistan doo doo Wonder
Woman in a present contemporary crisis
oh my god I mean not that you want her
to be like diverting this course of
history but half or divert the course of
history
yeah the [ __ ] movie
like let her divert the court of history
of course of history remember remember
when Quentin god bless him was like hey
in my movie they killed Hitler and we
were all like Hulu you can do this movie
they're like yeah we came here as they
need to do I'm killing it historical
idiots just Pol Pot just have a go in
there just take down despot because
that's what you should do all through
time yes
so Wonder Woman movie thumbs up go see
it because we want more of it and stuff
and don't go see it just because that's
a good reason to go see it goes against
[ __ ] vastly entertaining that no
man's land sequence is one of the finest
things you'll see in a cinema screen
this year and I'll go even further to
say that Beach sequence is worth the
price of admission yeah you can see a
lot of clips online but it's
breathtaking
because it's you know and there's
something to be said again we're two
dudes so we've seen dudes running around
shooting people for [ __ ] years but
there's something we said if you were a
young girl [ __ ] being an older woman if
you were just like some young girl who
like sat in that theater and you watched
that like you're like oh yeah this is
this is like if you're a young girl you
probably won't even realise that that's
not the norm that they've given you
something incredibly special so I guess
it is more for being an old girl if
you're old girl nobody wants to cop to
be an old girl but you know what I'm
talking to it's it's the movie that like
when you saw Star Wars and kid you're
like oh my god she shot somebody
thank God like a girl shot somebody it's
like that times a thousand I was her
doing every major thing that needs to be
done and yes Chris Pine and Steve Trevor
is there but he's not gonna dismiss him
as comic relief but he is not the hero
of the movie you know and he even does
something insanely heroic still not be
here and he's still not the hero of the
movie is from first to last her flick
and that's something huge man now and
you know what it also means like that's
the first one
first female lead of the big two
Marvel's got Captain Marvel that's their
female superhero lead movie that they're
going to do you know that now their game
they're like right we've seen what they
can do and it'll crack their knuckles
like let's build ours so that means you
going to get another strong female role
model superior
movie yeah I mean I had a friend who
told me that she felt the same way about
seeing this movie the way she felt she
was a kid the first time she ever saw a
woman in a business suit Justin Lee like
the optics of oh [ __ ] I didn't know you
could do now you know and like how
important that sort of thing is and
that's that's why I got emotional seeing
the movie like empathizing for people
for whom this is the first thing that
they've ever seen like this and it
absolutely led me to believe that I'm
gonna be a [ __ ] mess and black
panther ha ha ha I just all the [ __ ]
tears somebody wrote on Twitter when I
put up that tweet about you know right
before the movie the lady yelled out I
believe my life for this and somebody
wrote like that's what I yelled out when
I saw Black Panther at Civil War some
and he realized like even before I was
like man mark I've seen a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] like I've seen a bunch of
[ __ ] like not everyone gets equally
represented so what a thrilling time
where they're making stuff where kid can
look up to the screen and be like oh I
could do that that's me I can be that
character representation changes lives
if you can see it you can be there you
go
Wonder Woman is worth your time and
effort and money take a kid to see it
take yourself to see it take a lady
friend to go see it at a women-only
screen see it take your mother to see it
I'm gonna tell you know this is the
first [ __ ] a geeky comic action moving
a long time I do not have to convince my
wife to come with me to go see nice I
don't have to make a deal or side better
like I'll do this she was like I want to
go and I was like fantastic we win go
see it right now man DC Warner Brothers
well done patty Jenkins well done nice
job
gal gadot well done [ __ ] Claire from
that show Princess Bride Robin Rudd
great look amazing as you clever goods
our aquatic princess Buttercup uh Connie
Nielsen Jesus in the movie a little bit
yeah actually great Aleta but Chris Pine
I mean charming is [ __ ] oh my god as a
man you're just like I'd [ __ ] Steve
Trevor and that's not a spoiler I'm just
saying he's that charming right we're
going to [ __ ] Steve Jobs Oilers look out
by oh good you were there it is Batman
I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm Marvin
Arden
or really for fat man on Wonder Woman
and this is it I'm Kevin Smith I'm
marking our comeback next episode same
bat-time same bat-channel SModcast calm
or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]